async await feels like heaven because it  avoids the callback hell or pyramid of  doom  by writing asynchronous code in a clean  line-by-line format that is  until error handling comes into play  because you end up with the tri-catch  tower of terror all your beautiful  one-liners magically expand to at least  five lines of code  if you find yourself here the easy way  out is to append the catch method  to the end of each promise better but  that can still get repetitive  another option is to create a function  that implements one try catch to replace  all the others it first resolves the  promise then returns an array  where the first element is the data and  the second element is an error  but if there's an error then the data is  null and the error is defined  now when you call this function in your  code you can destructure it to get a  clean one-liner with error handling or  use a regular if statement if you want  to do something else with the error